[Applause]
it's gonna be difficult not to continue
that conversation this is John Perry
Barlow speaking with this man you know
one of the problems with with being a
techno utopian and and there were some
that were you know kind of obvious at
the time but in 20 years ago I made a
lot of giddy predictions about the
future and the weird thing is that all
of them have come true and they're not
as much fun as I thought they would be
in almost every instance you know I mean
I I used to go around telling people
that you know the internet was not about
content that was ridiculous it was about
conversation and it would only be you
know start to become itself as soon as
people got over trying to turn it into
interactive television and realized that
it was you know the audience talking
that was the deal but you know I've been
on Twitter for about a year and a half
I've got you know various as you devoted
tweak minions I don't know who they are
but they seem to have an attention span
of about 45 seconds you know I mean if
Jesus Christ had tweeted the Sermon on
the Mount you know Christian and you
would have lasted till nightfall you
know every once in a while you know it's
not like you actually get these things
you don't make things up I mean they're
given to you really good good things
suddenly come into your head every now
and again and I'll put you know and it
will seem profound it it might even be
profound I'll put it out there on
Twitter and I'll get like 25 retweets
and somebody will say who cool yeah and
there's gone and I you know
conversations persist yes
and you as one of the cofounders of the
e FF started a big conversation with
that and I'm one of the questions I
wanted to ask you is what were you
thinking
you know as usual I was trying to get
laid no I know I was I was thinking I
mean it was I had this I had this
religious experience the first time I
ever you know got into what I started
calling cyberspace so I I realized that
this was an enormous room that was about
to fill up with everybody yeah and then
it was gonna be bound realists and that
it was gonna have all these different
cultures in it and they were not gonna
have any idea how to deal with one
another I mean there were maybe five
hundred thousand people that had like
email addresses at that point but I
could see I mean you just do the math
everybody was gonna be there right
I mean in a relatively short period of
time and there was gonna be a huge
amount of confusion and upset and every
single existing structure power
relationship of the of the industrial
period at minimum and probably the
entire history of monotheism which I I
thought was also going to get severely
assaulted it was going to be up for
grabs and and there was going to be a
shitstorm in there that would require
somebody to be defending the right of
people to go on speaking as they chose
in this medium well it wasn't I soon
realized the medium and furthermore you
know the First Amendment was a local
ordinance and you know in fact rights as
I had thought of rights were not
something that could be ordained and we
had to start thinking about all right
how do we regulate human behavior in the
absence of government how do we create
new structures for human beings to
behave responsibly and you know we're
still a very young period on this but
dff has been doing this for 20 years and
you know it's a good thing we called
ourselves a frontier organization
because we knew we would be on the
frontier throughout always but I want
you know I want to talk to you but about
sexuality because I think you know if
you're talking about the future I think
you know the Internet does a lot of
things well and if you want to talk
about cultures rubbing up against each
other not liking each other right no
right and and and oh yeah absolutely and
the politics of sexuality in America
during my lifetime you know what are the
the conversation between the sexes has
been such a trip so it's great to be
talking to you I mean you think yourself
as a porn star in some respects no no no
no I know you're not a performer but I
mean you you have a a flame I mean you
know for example the Republic you know
the whatever it is of Libya I mean I
know whether Republic my friends in
Libya right your friends in Libya who
have decided that you know there is
something innately pornographic about
you know your presence there because
when somebody when somebody goes on
Twitter and and shortens one of your you
know a URL that you're making use of
suddenly you know the fact that it's got
a bit ly matters I mean you you have
been singled out yes absolutely and it
was it was really interesting teasing
out of them exactly what was obscene
illegal in pornographic about what the
site was doing right because and if
you're unfamiliar my business partner
and I we started a website called V Bly
based on Libyan domains when the domains
opened up and we're very popular like
bitly and we created a link shortening
service and when we did it it was never
intended as any type of a political act
it was simply intended as an alternate
link shortening service but why Libya
I mean wait why not because we're not
greenland er well because the domains
had just opened up and they were
marketing themselves to a Western
audience and to letters I got two
letters that were available and I read
through we read through all the terms
and conditions on the site as they were
at the time which they have sent to
change them and it didn't it didn't
strike you that Muammar Qaddafi was
be at least sort of nominally in control
of that domain not at all no not the
post mutters thinking well it's open
Internet I know I mean I this it's the
future that I predicted and here we are
yeah and so we we put one photograph on
it which was of me holding a beer
looking kind of smarmy with with my arms
bare and and simply said it was the
world's first sex positive link
shortening service in that we wouldn't
censor your links of course you know we
took out anything that was illegal
anything that was spam anything that was
problematic anything that would get
reported and we were very diligent and
they asked me to renew so we renewed and
about a month after we renewed they took
the domain offline and it took us a long
time to get in touch with them and
smartly kept a paper trail asking you
know eventually why why why then when we
could finally get to a human they said
what you're doing is illegal and you
know it and we said well what are we
doing and as it turned out we were
violating Sharia law which is Libyan
religious law and which I thought is
applied to the Internet as applied to
the Internet and it wasn't we had no
content on the site except for the
photograph it was a service we were
running off of the site so we actually
had no people were emailing me going
where was the poor on your site well I
know I mean can you show me now and no
in the in the resulting kerfuffle I I
mean that was the point at which you
know and I've been familiar with you
work for a while and you know suddenly
somebody referred to you as a porn star
and I said wait a second you know this
is this is how well I mean but that was
probably an artifact of old media ya
know that's and that's new media too in
a very interesting way
ya know but I didn't we didn't use to
have media like that before
I don't think no what I thought was was
interesting was that okay you know the
the idea of whether or not the website
was a political statement completely
doesn't matter when you think about the
idea of religion and religious law being
applied to the policing
is a political statement isn't it well
it has nobody don't you think it was all
along I mean you you seem to have an
angle that is that puts a political
context around your sexuality maybe not
what's that I just notice it whenever I
get into a fight it ends up in the New
York Times so maybe maybe it's just what
is better than the New York Post you're
getting in the right kind of vibe
what I think is interesting from any
angle is is that when you when you when
you have religious law and an open
Internet suddenly you're in an enormous
gray area well that was the idea I mean
you know and and it will go on being
gray you know it's very but you know
there is this relationship between
cyberspace and meatspace it is it's very
interesting I mean it's it's just
exactly the relationship between the
mind and the body so it sort sort of
germane here you know I mean you know
that there's the mind units abstraction
and you know that there is the body and
it's concreteness a squishy concreteness
yes but you know the area between those
two things is is and always has been and
always probably will be a very difficult
zone to define I think so I think and
that's going to be true on this planet
as a mine from don't you think yes
absolutely I think I think the
controversy though that you were
suggesting about my message is that it's
a sex positive message and that is that
is who's not for sex oh I get a lot of
excuse me there I guess there we were
nervous about it but I mean I think
basically everybody's pretty much for it
well you would think so I mean there are
a lot of people in the world yeah but I
mean when you come from the approach
that it's an inherently good thing it's
pretty upsetting to some people
apparently yeah
oh no I mean I guess yeah I mean it but
it seems it seems generally to be
upsetting to people who are devoutly
attached to one of the three major
monotheistic religions maybe yeah that's
a narrow characterization but it strikes
me that all three of those religions are
as as I thought they would be under very
severe attack from the internet by
virtue of their their having a a
doctrine based on a very concrete set of
spoke of written words they have a book
they all have a book set of books and
now we are creating you know books upon
books upon books upon books of opinion
and and other countervailing argument
and you know a very pantheistic model
you know and they're reacting in this
way and sexuality just happens to be one
of the you think it's just like one of
the battlements that they have chosen
yes with which to protect themselves
against the general horde of horizontal
ISM as opposed to vertical ISM glad to
find the wrist one there do you think
that distribution ideas that run counter
to two cultures that need to maintain
their rules in their laws specifically
like their rules and laws to to keep the
status quo do you what do you see as as
the future in this respect do you think
that there's going to be such
dissemination of information that these
cultures either must evolve or they get
blown apart or do you see them
tightening down and clamping down and
well I'm I'm an old acid head so I
appoint in about 1966 in this city where
I thought that God was about to jump
through the transom and you know and
everything you know a new age would be
upon us immediately and you know then
everything started to believe the rails
to the point where I was even alarmed
and then
you know then there was the
understandable reaction of all of the
powers that had been to this way of
looking at things that was fundamentally
disturbing you know it was about you
know the end of god-given Authority it
was about you know turning humanity into
into a spiritual species that had a
direct unmediated contact with the holy
that didn't come through the book or
anything else and I have seen you know
the last 40 years of American history
American history be nothing but this
endless horrible battle between the 50s
and the 60s between monotheism and
pantheism in between you know the
seriously endangered forces of what had
been the status quo up to that point in
a state of reaction and just because I
think monotheism is on it's going to be
on its last legs for the next two or
three hundred years doesn't mean it's
going to be easy to be around it if
you're locked in the closet with a dying
dinosaur the fact that he is more
abundant as his faint comfort and so and
I don't know you know I think it's brave
what you do I mean like you know and I
think it's important and and the FF does
what it does to make sure that what you
do can go on being done as many places
as possible though I mean I I also think
that we have to learn how to be somewhat
less in one another's face about this
stuff I mean I find that people are very
intolerant of the religious now and very
and very inflexible in their in their
attitude towards what they perceive
perceived to be the inflexibility of the
religious do you see that just as
unnecessary reaction I don't know there
is a necessary reaction that's just it
yeah you know I mean I think the
could be that the the advisable reaction
not not the predictable one but the
advisable reaction is somewhat more
tolerant I'm not even tolerant I mean I
think I don't like the word tolerant I
think it's because it's kind of sending
as hell nice you know it is I mean I
like tolerate you I don't want to be
tolerated I want to be respected I don't
you know a lot of people would agree
with you yeah they say you know
tolerance is you know it's it's what's
bandied about in mainstream media as
this is how we accept the other no and
it's no and furthermore I mean I think
that you know as far as tolerance is
concerned you know the first business of
tolerance is to be that minimum tolerant
toward that which would not tolerate you
yes I mean that's you know if you can't
get that one right the rest of it is
junk Liberty resides in the rights of
that person whose views you find most
odious as is what John Stuart Mill said
and that includes people that you know
that includes unfortunately at the
moment some people that that are
protesting it servicemen's funerals
because they say that you know they've
died to defend homosexuality do you
think that around that because there has
been so much outcry and activism online
in this particular instance against
Westboro isn't it yeah I mean I don't
want to single them out I mean but I
only single them out as being an example
of something that I find hard to defend
but nevertheless necessary right do you
believe that there is a self-correcting
nature of the open Internet in this well
you know this is another one you know I
you see what is truth right and and and
and in reality as far as I know is just
you know that the story that we
collectively tell ourselves about it I
mean preferably collectively sometimes
you know not but
[Music]
I just felt like we would you know enter
into this great conversation where there
would be a natural sort of corrective to
to untruth you know that you didn't need
to worry about slander because you know
good speech would drive out bad and and
there is evidence that this can work in
is working I mean Wikipedia I mean to me
Wikipedia is one of the most optimistic
generations of the human race that I've
ever seen it I mean it is phenomenal I
knew Jimmy Wales when he was first
airing and I said you know you have an
even more sunny view of humanity than I
do and I'm pretty optimistic well we'll
see how it goes and I have yet to read
anything there that I don't think is
accurate that I know about personally I
have had a stalker who threatened me
personally editing the Wikipedia page
about me for the past four years yeah
but they were corrected and has
published my address on Wikipedia on my
Wikipedia page and so I think it's um I
think there's a lot of conflict in that
optimism okay well I mean yeah but I
mean actually the other the other part
of it is that there's there is all sorts
but I mean the other part of it is that
there are you know Wikipedia I was gonna
say is a good example and even within
that there are as you say lamentable
consequences of human beings being
themselves but you know they're they're
also you know I I realized now that
there are a lot of people who are not
interested in the truth actually I mean
that they don't like you know it's easy
enough to find out whether or not Barack
Obama is a Muslim but nevertheless 19
percent of the American people believe
that he is and actually do not have any
interest in not believing that he is so
I mean the truth is what you want to
believe too it's subjective thank you so
much talk to you for 19 well let's do
that we don't have to we don't have to
restrict the conversation to this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you